why not both part two just the other day
I talked about why not both when I was
talking about quality and quantity about
content and today making a quick little
video because I feel like a lot of
people asking me a question about what
happened today which was Fast Company
reported that I'm working on another
agency called brief story to represent
fine celebrities which is true and on
the same day Facebook and Instagram
announcing that they're doing now video
15-second videos on their platform and
of course I see all these comments and
alec vine is dead or or this will be
another poke and it won't work for
instagram they'll be like kind of the
snapchat poke thing and my question is
why not both why can't both Instagram
15-second non-moving videos and vine
6-second looping videos work you know
Facebook and Twitter work they're
different enough they're both at scale
they're also backed by the number one
and two social networks in the world so
to give you my official answer which is
the question I've been asked so much on
Twitter why not both I think both win I
have nothing but respect for doctrine
Kevin Systrom to the best in the game I
have incredible respect for Don Hoffman
and vine team and the Twitter peeps I
think both are gonna win I think of
different I think you've got story-tell
differently one is ironically long-form
15 seconds one is shorter form six
seconds I think they're gonna have
different shouldn'ts different needs
different people will pop out and be
successful on both some people are good
at status updates on Facebook and not on
Twitter and vice versa this is a place
where I see both winning